[Música]
y
por primera vez uno de los tantos
procesos que tiene en su contra la ex
presidenta y actual vicepresidenta de
argentina cristina fernández de kirchner
llega a juicio y también es la primera
vez en la que piden una pena en su
contra 12 años de cárcel e inhabilidad
política de por vida presuntamente por
incidir en que le adjudicaran más de 50
contratos a un empresario amigo pero aún
queda mucho camino por recorrer pues
todavía faltan los alegatos de la
defensa de cada uno de los 13 acusados
en el caso conocido como vialidad
incluidos los de fernández de kirchner y
esto sólo comenzará a partir del 5 de
septiembre además el fallo que tome el
tribunal oral federal entre finales de
este año y principios del otro puede ser
apelado y recurrido ante dos instancias
distintas por lo que aún falta mucho
tiempo para una decisión final sin
embargo la petición del ministerio
público contra una de las figuras más
visibles del peronismo están dividiendo
aún más argentinas se trata de hacer
justicia como lo enseña la del
ministerio público o una persecución
judicial y mediática como lo alega el
oficialismo de la cárcel la
vicepresidenta lo analizamos en nuestro
debate de hoy y comenzamos escuchando
las palabras del fiscal diego luciano
esta parte solicita se condene
a cristina elisabet fernández al apenas
12 años de prisión inhabilitación
especial perpetua para ejercer cargos
públicos accesorias legales el pago de
las costas por considerar la autora
penalmente responsable de los delitos
socialista agravada por su calidad de
jefa y de administración fraudulenta
agravada por haber sido cometida en
perjuicio una administración pública que
concurren de manera real ante esta
petición del fiscal federal así se
defendió cristina fernández los fiscales
pudieron leer su guión durante nueve
jornadas me hubiera gustado
poder también
hablar frente al tribunal no debía
sorprenderme porque tal como dije en
aquella oportunidad
la sentencia ya estaba escrita y para
analizar este tema nos acompaña fernando
morroni periodista y analista político y
también tenemos a eduardo géromé abogado
especializado en derecho penal y quien
fue juez en argentina antes de pesar le
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación
en sus preguntas y comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
twitter instagram y facebook en donde no
se encuentran como france24 raya al piso
y también en mi cuenta personal mariah
que aguirre la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 en youtube pueden seguir
nuestra señal en streaming saludamos a
las personas que nos escuchan también en
nuestro podcast y los invito para que
escuchen todos los contenidos del
programa que están disponibles en app el
podcast spotify deezer y tuning
y ahora si comenzamos hablando del caso
por el que procesan a cristina fernández
de kirchner una auditoría de la
dirección nacional de vialidad detectó
en 2016 que el 78 por ciento de las
obras adjudicadas en la provincia de
santa cruz entre 2013 y 2015 fueron para
un grupo de empresas de lázaro báez y
aquí hay tres cosas puntuales la
provincia es un fortín de los kirchner
pues allí gobernó durante más de una
década
néstor kirchner ese periodo corresponde
a las presidencias de kirchner y de su
esposa cristina fernández
y además vice es amigo de la
vicepresidenta y quiero comenzar
preguntándole al señor jerome según esto
y las pruebas que se conocen pudo haber
intercedido cristina fernández para
otorgar esos contratos
no pudo no haber intercedido porque eran
de una entidad tan grande era imposible
que esto quedara en manos de segundos
eran muchísimo dinero a tal punto que se
determinó que eran cerca de cinco mil
millones de pesos
realmente una verdadera fortuna y a
quien se le daba eran concesiones de
obras públicas que se daban a gente que
no tenía ninguna experiencia en este
tema quién era este señor lázaro báez
lázaro báez era un empleado de un banco
de la provincia de santa cruz donde
conoció a los kirchner cuando él era
gobernador cuando era intendente de la
ciudad
resulta que este señor lázaro va es de
ser un simple empleado bancario
pocos días antes de la asunción de
kirchner como presidente aparece creando
una empresa de obras públicas y oh
casualidad
pocos días después de que asume el
presidente kirchner es
concesionario para realizar obras
públicas y así fue que se le otorgaron
en detrimento de muchas otras empresas
que tenían y obviamente tenían
antecedentes de construcción de obras y
no esta gente que no las tenía que cobro
a lo largo de todos estos años que
gobernaron los kirchner que fueron 12
cobro por obras que algunas al principio
se hicieron otras no se hicieron no se
terminaron por la mitad pero cobró todo
y con un con un agravante que lo destaca
de terriblemente que es que al día
siguiente al día siguiente que la señora
de kirchner deja de ser presidente esta
empresa se desinfló hecho a todos sus
empleados cayó en quiebra bueno
realmente algo que está una connivencia
con el poder muy grande todo esto
declara fue
valorado no por el fiscal lusianni que
es el que le hizo esta acusación que
usted acaba de reseñar no esto fue
valorado por un tribunal que intervino
en la primera instancia de la causa un
juzgado que la procesó a esta señora un
fiscal que acompañó ese procesamiento
esto fue apelado fue recurrido ante una
ante una cámara superior que confirmó
este procesamiento sea otros tres jueces
dijeron que era necesario que fuera
sometida a un juicio oral se la somete o
un fiscal la está acusando con sobradas
pruebas y hemos analizado que ella dice
que no la dejaron hablar lo cual es
interrumpir lo voy a interrumpir porque
justo vamos a analizar esos detalles del
proceso más adelante pero antes quiero
darle la bienvenida también al señor
borrón nos acompaña al igual que el
señor oyeron desde argentína señor
borrón y para usted pudo haber
intercedido o no cristina fernández en
este caso
qué tal
clara eduardo a ver lo primero quiero
primero aclarar algunas cuestiones que
esgrimió embargo que no son así
como primer punto no es cierto que la
empresa de lázaro va desea y nada ha
recibido mayor obra pública durante el
gobierno de los kirchner
segundo vamos a atenernos a la causa
con un dato que seguramente lo conozcan
pero si no lo conocen hacia la coyuntura
que después lo vamos a profundizar
acerca de quién es el fiscal luciano
porque aquí hay que decir estamos frente
a un hecho claramente de los ofer que
busca la prescripción política de
cristina kirchner y que la justicia no
encontró ni una sola prueba
pero más allá del discurso de cada uno
no encontró una sola prueba que
involucra cristina fernández de kirchner
de las 51 obras de la que se le acusa
lázaro báez y que la presidente está
involucrada en la asignación de esas
obras de las 51 49 fueron descartadas
de las restantes que quedan no hubo un
solo testigo en la causa testigos
pedidos por el fiscal judicial que haya
nombrado siquiera la cristina fernández
de kirchner quiero decir esto con
claridad cristina fernández de kirchner
no está nombrada en la causa por ningún
testigo no está nombrada no existe en la
uc concretamente con una prueba firme
dicho tener en cuenta y esto no es una
cuestión opinable
esto basta con ver la causa
por otro para no decir porque este es el
argumento del fiscal luciano y la
presidenta de la nación no podía no
saber qué pasaba con alguna en su obrar
y por tanto es jefa de una asociación
ilícita es de una vergüenza jurídica
creer que un presidente o una presidenta
de la nación por ejercer ese cargo sabe
lo que hacen los centenares y centenares
de funcionarios hombres y mujeres visten
los distintos ministerios y en los
distintos estamentos del poder judicial
es francamente
una lógica que sólo busca judicial izar
la política
insisto con esto no hay pruebas no hay
pruebas de un fiscal como lucían y
seguramente maría clara no sabes ni un
fiscal como luciana que
amigo del ex residente de mauricio macri
y es amigo del juez de la causa que
jugaban juntos en la quinta los
registros donde jugaba el presidente
mauricio macri y jóvenes del mismo tipo
de fútbol quiero decir el fiscal que
acusa el juez quiera juzgar y quien
conduce la oposición a christina aquí se
haría este gobierno de mauricio macri
los tres son compañeros de un equipo de
fútbol tiene decena de fotos se
mostraron aquí por algunos medios por
tanto ya por ese elemento el juicio está
viciado y debería al menos abrir una
investigación si sumo un dato más para
luego poder dialogar con él con eduardo
aquí hay algo importante que demostró el
otro día la vicepresidenta cuando hizo
su defensa por las redes
de los de los mensajes de whatsapp que
hay con el que era secretaria dólar
pública
lópez que fue
detectando un maestro de corrupción unos
bolsos llenos de dólares
con ese personaje corrupto que si formo
parte del entramado de la estructura del
gobierno del gobierno de pekín aquí si
el que está preso
con esa persona clase nova de tubos el
mensaje de texto
con la mano derecha de mauricio macri
que nicky caputo tuvo más de 110 después
si quieren esto lo ampliamos porque no
es el único que aparece
lo voy a interrumpir porque quiero
profundizar en algo que usted mencionó y
fueron las fotografías que se conocieron
del fiscal luciano y del juez rodrigo
jiménez que preside el tribunal que
fallara en el caso de cristina fernández
y le quiero preguntar sobre esto al
señor jerome especialmente después de
que borrón y nos hablara de una
judicialización de la política que están
en duda puede estar la acción del
tribunal y del fiscal con estas
fotografías
bueno yo no coincido con la opinión de
fernando por roaming porque realmente no
es exacto eso sino que
el fiscal y él y uno de los jueces de la
causa jugaban juntos en un equipo de
fútbol lo cual no quiere decir en
absoluto que sean amigos ni mucho menos
que tengan ningún otro tipo de
connivencia es muy común yo he estado en
tribunales he estado en el poder
judicial y uno jugaba al tenis jugaba al
fútbol había torneos dentro del poder
judicial etcétera y todos jugamos entre
nosotros pero nadie por eso era amigo
éramos simplemente amigos del amigo pero
no del resto de los jugadores etcétera
teníamos amigos y conocidos conocidos
son todos porque en el ambiente jurídico
en el ambiente político conocido son la
gran mayoría eso no significa que nadie
vaya a torcer su voluntad porque lo
conocen o son amigos y respecto de lo
que dijo por robbie de de el presidente
macri el presidente para que no jugaba
en el equipo con ellos no no no
simplemente que en una donde se jugaba
al fútbol y había torneos en algún
momento jugó este equipo pero nunca lo
vieron a macri como ellos han dicho ni
mucho menos y macri no jugó al fútbol
con ellos por ende está este descrédito
que se quiere hacer es completamente
injustificado y voy más allá porque se
quiere desacreditar al fiscal y a los
jueces porque como no se encontró
ninguna prueba para desacreditar el la
acusación entonces se ataca a los jueces
para decir bueno estos lo pudieron haber
juzgado pero la vicepresidente cristina
fernández tuvo toda la ocasión para
defenderse cuando hacía uso de la
palabra solamente decía que la
perseguían decía que ella era víctima
del lo fer era pero nunca dijo esta
concesión fue correcta porque acá no se
perdió plata esto sucedió de esta otra
manera
no nunca hizo una defensa jurídica de su
caso y además por otra parte pensar en
que hay una confabulación
contra alguien contra un funcionario
cuando ha pasado por múltiples jueces
como yo le dije ya de por si un juez de
primera instancia más tres o cuatro más
un fiscal más ahora otro fiscal más el
tribunal que está constituido por tres
miembros o sea pensar en una
connivencia de todos ellos para atacar a
una vicepresidente que por otra parte si
dijéramos que está limpia de polvo y
paja en todo lo demás bueno yo hasta no
es que lo podría entender pero me podría
dudar no la vicepresidente quiere ir
cristina fernández fue procesada en 10
causas por múltiples cosas la
vicepresidente tiene una fortuna que no
puede explicar no puede explicar porque
siempre desempeñó la función pública
mire simplemente él secretario privado
del presidente kirchner un señor muñoz
tiene propiedades en miami por valor de
64 millones de dólares ahora quién me
puede decir que un secretario privado de
un presidente puede tener esa cantidad
de dinero esa cantidad de propiedades y
unos productos realmente de ser un
testaferro y de casos de corrupción
absoluta administrativa como puede ser
que también los bolsos y bolsos que la
secretaria del presidente kirchner la
holgura de las secretarias privadas
también del se cree presidente kirchner
que se llamaba miriam quiroga declaró
que ella vería los bolsos que iban a las
casas particulares del presidente y de
la vicepresidente
bueno todo eso es absolutamente
innegable los ministros lo voy a pedir a
ambos que puedan tener posturas más
concretas para que podamos utilizar bien
el tiempo y darle la palabra al señor
bron y para que le responda al señor
vieron sobre todo cuando él dice que es
innegable que es innegable las diez
causas que tiene la vicepresidenta y que
no está línea de polvo como dice el
señor quiero
responder respecto a lo primero que
quiero decir maría clara que es muy
difícil separar algún debate si ponemos
cosas que no son verdad que debate sobre
verdades todas las causas de la que
acusaron a cristina fernández de
kirchner te cayeron una tras otra porque
no hay elementos en las causas en las
que cristina kirchner dona al futuro
también que pase la justicia usted lo
sabe doctor sabe que funciona justicia
que hay ausencia de delito
de la causa del blanco unidad sabe que
fallo la justicia que hay ausencia de
delito
sabe que dijo el juez ercolini sobre
esta misma causa en instancias
inferiores que dice que las investigando
la juzgaron los vasos funcionales se
corrió de la causa no encontraron
elementos
reconocer la persecución política que
llevó adelante
aquí el multimedio clarín
juntos por el cambio y un sector de la
justicia que constitución partido
judicial realmente falta la verdad acá
tenemos fiscales más claras seguro sabe
saca tenemos fiscales como stornelli que
junto con periodista del diario clarín
esperaban a gente de la oposición y
montaron un grandes operaciones
políticas que se cayeron como la causa
de los cuadernos un invento absoluto de
un supuestamente el chofer que iba
anotando en un cuaderno lo que hacía y
cómo se llevaban estos bolsos de dinero
pero la otro no existe el cuaderno aquí
se puso al hijo de la presidenta máximo
kirchner con la ex secretaria de
seguridad
de tener cuenta que paraísos fiscales en
las islas seychelles y no existe en el
banco pues tapa del diario clarín aquí
se habló años de la ruta del dinero que
se llevó adelante una investigación con
varios medios y periodistas de
investigación de varios medios
internacionales y en la búsqueda de el
dinero de la ruta acá por los kirchner
encontraron el dinero de la ruta m
encontraron a 55 cuentas opción de
mauricio macri no es cierto que cristina
n 10 causas donde está haciendo
investigar entonces cayeron 11 las
causas una de las causas que investigaba
por ejemplo el juego en sí contra
mauricio macri hasta que para el doctor
no es importante que fiscal y el juez de
la causa se vayan a buscar a una quinta
donde jugar persiguen de mauricio macri
debo decirle que el juez borinsky por
ejemplo en 21 de las causas con vecinas
curaba el padre en la quinta de olivos
con mauricio macri y aclaró interrumpo
aquí el 20 grupo para poder avanzar en
otros temas que no quiero que se me
pierdan y sobre todo precisar como usted
lo dice en efecto tres de las causas
contra la vice president se cayeron
antes de llegar a juicio precisamente
porque los jueces consideraron que no
había delito pero si hay una que sigue
abierta aunque todavía no ha comenzado
el juicio y es la causa de los cuadernos
de la corrupción que precisamente usted
mencionó pero pasemos a otro punto y es
la respuesta que ha dado el oficialismo
para en defensa de cristina fernández un
poco los argumentos son parecidos a los
que hemos visto aquí ellos hablan de un
love air y de un acoso judicial y
mediático contra la vicepresidenta y el
presidente de alberto fernández quien
fue quien la eligió como su fórmula
vicepresidencial ha sido uno de los
mayores defensores pero tuvo una salida
en falso en una entrevista televisiva
con el canal todo noticias y es que
cuando le preguntaron qué opinaba sobre
la seguridad que habían redoblado para
el fiscal el presidente dijo y luego
textualmente alentar que le pueda pasar
al fiscal lucian y lo que le pasó a
nisman miren hasta acá lo que le pasó al
fiscal nisman es que se suicidó hasta
acá no se probó otra cosa yo espero que
no que no haga algo así el fiscal
luciana y recordemos que alberto nisman
fue el fiscal a quien encontraron muerto
en su casa con en la cabeza y quien
acusó a cristina kirchner cristina
fernández de kirchner debe haber
conspirado con irán para encubrir a los
presuntos responsables de un ataque de
terrorista en 1994 vamos con eduardo es
eso una amenaza como lo afirman los
opositores de la coalición cívica- y que
tanta independencia puede haber en este
caso con esa frase
como primera medida es una absoluta
intromisión del poder ejecutivo sobre la
independencia de los poderes nuestro
país es una república y la constitución
fija que el sistema está basado en tres
poderes que deben ser independientes
entre sí pues el presidente ha no solo
hecho una crítica tremenda y permanente
sobre el poder judicial para defender a
quien verdaderamente ejerce el poder en
la argentina porque no es ningún secreto
que aquí hay un presidente nominal y hay
una vicepresidente que es la que tiene
el poder pues entonces en su afán de
agradar a la vicepresidente el
presidente fernández se ha pasado
haciendo crítica entrometiéndose de
poder judicial y prácticamente en lo que
indudablemente puede ser considerado un
amedrentamiento una amenaza que ha
merecido que las asociaciones de
magistrados y de funcionarios públicos
del país hayan salido acá comunicado
permanente la asociación de magistrado
en la asociación de jueces republicanos
los colegios de abogados
comunicados alarmados y repudiando esta
actitud de interferencia en el poder
judicial porque no se puede llamar de
otra cosa y por otra parte permítame
maría clara decir que el fiscal russian
y quien lo nombró el decreto de
nombramiento del fiscal lusianni tiene
la firma de cristina fernández de
kirchner o sea no fue nombrado por el
presidente macri ni por nada lo nombró y
llega lo que pasa es que ahora como no
le conviene pasa a ser una especie de
anti juez anti fiscal etcétera si
pasamos nos pasamos a fernando que vamos
a hacer nadie porque se nos se nos acaba
el tiempo fernando usted qué opina de
esto eduardo dice que si hay una
interferencia y usted previamente había
dicho que hay una politización de la
justicia
tratamiento mucho que te lamento mucho
que sus televidentes tengan que contar
con todo respeto lo digo tengan que
escuchar
semejantes arte de la entidad porque el
discurso el doctor gero mes discúlpeme
que me enoje pero es muy violento lo que
se vive acá en la argentina lo que se
vivió durante los cuatro años de
mauricio macri por una clara persecución
política con presos políticos sin
pruebas aquí se hicieron adelante una
teoría es que la televisión tiene
imagino el doctor que no eran del la
debería rechazar como abogado que
automáticamente una persona estaba
procesada que no tenía probada su
culpabilidad
como tenía algún vínculo o había tenido
algún vínculo con algún sector político
que le podía elche impunidad por la duda
y aprecio
esto pasó aquí en el argentina esté
decir que en argentina la justicia es
independiente es una vergüenza es una
vergüenza que los ojos del mundo porque
aquí hay cama a ver yo no sé cómo
explicar una malla sintética maria clara
aquí hay filmaciones del funcionario del
gobierno mauricio macri con funcionarios
de servicio diferenciar vinculados con
jueces firmados organizando detenciones
de dirigentes sindicales
entonces primer escenario ese segundo
escenario es mejor la calidad se cayó la
causa también
porque no había un solo elemento se
lamentó que cada vez que habla a alguien
en compra descriptiva kirchner porque
esto es en contra del quiche porque
tiene esperanzas de gran parte de los
argentinos las argentinas no darle un
solo elemento y resultó que el estrógeno
me diga bueno a ver les piden 12 años de
prisión en la causa de vialidad por tal
prueba tal prueba hasta el prueba no
tienen una sola prueba porque
simplemente el argumento de no
corrupción y en resolución y decir que
es como presidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner tenía que es hablar no se
cuentan al día de cosas saben eso es
imposible
ahora en este país mauricio macri ésta
fue el correo argentino mauricio macri
tiene 55 cuentas de opción mauricio
macri envió a los familiares de las
víctimas del haras san juan que es
indios y marinos de unión
mauricio macri está vinculado a destinos
de hecho de corrupción no no se
investiga a nadie porque los fiscales y
los jueces sobre todo comodoro py son
fiscales y jueces visitado por el señor
el tormento que es el dueño y medio
me dio más grandes que tiene para que
nos demos un inicio bonito variación
pero pero volvamos nos vamos alcance
volvamos al caso de cristina fernández
señor fernando y le quiero preguntar
algo usted dice que cristina sigue
siendo un poco la esperanza para el país
y de hecho tanto ella como su esposo
néstor kirchner han sido figuras
visibles del peronismo que implicaría
una posible sentencia en su contra se
dividiría más el país como lo está y
como lo hemos visto en este debate
el país está dividido por la desigualdad
[Música]
desde cristina kirchner habló el otro
día porque quiero decir cuando
cristina tuvo tiempo para defenderse y
que no lo hizo y que ahora le impidió
hablar no lo consiguieron no el tema es
que ella se dé se envía un sobre un
pinar una pila de organizaciones que nos
vieron fundamental luego en la mitad del
proceso le metieron más acusaciones de
financiar defenderse ese no lo dejaron a
partir del día que habló cristina
kirchner por las redes en todo el país
hay movilizaciones y hay marchas
defendiendo discusión porque saben acá
es muy claro maría clara lo que pasa en
acá la gente sabe lo que pasa cuál es el
problema que vos de 100 medios y radio
televisión y diarios 85% de la manera un
85% pero tenés en un solo dependiente
que tiene forma de sequía sigue siendo
la líder política más importante es que
están haciendo los mismos que hicieron
engarce lula de silva para que no puede
ser presidente
quiero retomar ese punto que usted
menciona de luiz inácio lula da silva
fernando para preguntarle a eduardo y
varios presidentes latinoamericanos se
han pronunciado a favor de la
vicepresidenta como es el caso del
mandatario colombiano gustavo petro del
mismo alberto fernández de luis arce en
bolivia etcétera sin embargo hay dos
silencios que llaman la atención y es el
del presidente chileno gabriel boric y
el del expresidente brasileño luiz
inácio lula da silva que como lo
acabamos de ver muchas personas en
argentina comparan su caso con el de
cristina fernández eduardo a qué se
deben estos silencios bueno es que al
revés de lo que opina fernando borrón
que entre paréntesis y quiero decir algo
que me parece que yo no estoy de acuerdo
con lo que ha dicho con nada pero sin
embargo no digo que es una sarta de
mentiras porque me parece que esto ni
que es violento lo que dice porque me
parece que este es un tema muy
kirchnerista donde se divide la sociedad
nosotros y ellos y se descalifica al que
opina distinto esto no estoy de acuerdo
pero quiero decirles que cristina
fernández de kirchner si hubiera tenido
suficiente con para ser presidente
hubiera sido ella la candidata no pudo
serlo tuvo que traer a otra persona que
tenía fama de moderado porque sabía que
sino no la hubieran elegido y ahora no
va a haber proscripción de ningún tipo
es absolutamente falso porque para que
haya una imposibilidad de que se
presente esta causa tiene que estar
terminada con sentencia firme lo cual no
va a ocurrir antes de las próximas
elecciones es decir cristina kirchner
puede presentarse a lo que quiera ahora
a que se va a presentar a la candidatura
presidente sepamos lo y guardemos este
comentario sepamos lo que no porque no
se va a presentar porque sería una
derrota estrepitosa
entonces dónde va a ir a refugiarse ella
no va a querer perder sus fueros
entonces va a querer ser reelegida como
senadora por la provincia de buenos
aires como senadora tiene fueros que le
van a impedir seguir presa entonces ella
va a elegir
ese camino y no para presentarse como
presidente porque si ella tuviera la
certeza o la confianza de que la
elegiría no cabe duda que se presentaría
como candidata no va a suceder y el
tiempo lo va a demostrar ella quiere
solamente mantener sus fueros para no ir
presa es lo único que le importa la
situación del país en estos momentos es
dramática terrorífica con la situación
de niveles de pobreza como nunca se han
conocido un índice de inflación pero que
está llegando al 100 por ciento anual
como lo que se conoce en la historia de
este país y sin embargo lo único que les
importa las autoridades en este momento
es tratar de estafar a una persona que
tiene múltiples causas por corrupción y
entre ellas está causa de los 'cuadernos
no se cayó esta causa de los cuadernos
está plenamente vigente y también va a
ser un lastre que va a arrastrar a esta
señora a otro gran problema porque marca
la corrupción que se vivía en esa edad
todos sus funcionarios terminó con esto
la mayoría de los que fueron ministros y
secretarios de cristina kirchner hoy en
día están procesados por distintos
ciclos de corrupción eduardo 30 segundos
para responder a la pregunta que le hice
y que no me respondió y es a qué se debe
el silencio de luisina lee luiz inácio
lula da silva
porque creo que están considerando que
es totalmente distinta la situación de
lula da silva en brasil con la de
cristina kirchner acá donde deberán
haber analizado la cantidad de pruebas
que hay en contra y que prueban la
corrupción y que el políticamente ha
dicho seguramente que la vinculación con
cristina kirchner sería un flaco favor
que le haría a él en brasil que la
comparen con una persona que está
acusada de semejante hechos de
corrupción que como lo ha dicho el
fiscal son lo más grande que se han
conocido en la historia de este país
fernando y ahora con ustedes la misma
pregunta cómo entender el silencio de
luiz inácio lula da silva y también
darle la réplica a algo que dijo eduardo
y es cristina fernández solo quiere
mantener sus fueros para no terminar en
la cárcel
estuvo por lo menos dos años sin fueros
y no fue presa porque no le encontraba
una prueba en los juicios
es decir
estuvo cien fueron seis
eso por un lado
por el otro lado los distintos apoyos
que se expresaron hacia la
vicepresidenta desde birmajer hasta lo
que usted mencionaba en otras partes del
continente hasta desde francia se han
pronunciado webs de apoyar a christine a
ser particularmente en una masiva no lo
ha hecho público
seguramente tendrá que ver con la
campaña pero quédense muy tranquilos del
lazo político afectivo de confianza y de
credibilidad
en asia y lula da silva no lo perfora
nadie que tiene aquí ya plenamente dijo
desde aquí siempre es quien hace una
ciudad fue víctima de una operación
política demencial para sacarlo de la
carrera electoral lo mismo está viviendo
con respecto a lo de pedir respeto a lo
último o sea muy breve y puede redondear
en 30 segundos para nosotros ya
aproximarnos a la conclusión te muestro
pierre pero insisto que lo digo con lo
que le manifesté al doctor gero no es
personal y no es una falta de respeto lo
violento la mentira lo violento la
mentira entonces no podemos construir
seguir construyendo esta idea del
kirchnerismo como el enemigo interno en
la argentina ojalá y cierro con esto
hicieron lo mismo con lula hicieron lo
mismo con dilma rousseff con golpe
institucional hicieron lo mismo con
rafael correa estoy sitiado en bélgica
por una causa inventada hicieron lo
mismo le dieron un golpe institucional a
zelaya en honduras hicieron lo mismo con
lugo en paraguay dieron un golpe de
estado en bolivia
con evo morales y la verdad es que luego
cuando los pueblos van a las urnas
siguen diciendo esos gobiernos populares
eduardo pero fernando
para pasar a la conclusión la última
pregunta les voy a pedir que sean muy
concretos tenemos menos de 1 minuto para
cada respuesta eduardo géromé terminará
en la cárcel la vicepresidenta argentina
cristina fernández de kirchner
no sé si va a terminar en la cárcel
porque hay dos circunstancias que lo van
a impedir una de ellas es como les dije
el hecho de que ella va a conservar lo
fuero siendo senadora para evitar ir a
la cárcel y por otra parte también que
ya está próxima a cumplir 70 años y
entonces la ley dice que en ese caso se
le puede dar prisión domiciliaria pero
pero lo que a mí no me cabe duda es que
va a ser condenada y la ignominia la
vergüenza de ser condenada por un delito
que es de corrupción al estado que es
considerado un delito pero que va contra
el sistema democrático un delito que es
prácticamente de lesa humanidad porque
viola los derechos humanos vaya si los
viola con 5 mil millones de pesos se
podrían haber construido
centenares de colegios escuelas para
educación si eso no es violar derechos
humanos donde está esa violación de
derechos humanos vaya clara y ahora
vamos con fernando muy brevemente
en la cárcel o
no en la cárcel no va a terminar
condenada porque el fangio ya está
escrito porque la intencionalidad es
política realmente decir que es víctima
quisiera violador a derechos humanos por
lo llevado adelante la política de
derechos humanos más importante meta
para la democracia néstor kirchner y
ella y quiero decir que si cristina
entre otras entre otras cosas no fue
candidata en el 2019 pues porque decidió
ser madre y curar a su hija que estaba
enferma a causa de la presión del
partido judicial y los medios que la
acusaron de ser parte de una acción
ilícita cuando ella tenía 12 años chips
una barbaridad ojalá alguno entienda lo
que significa el poder judicial
comunicacional aquí en la argentina que
tiene aquí ya no va a ir presa porque
hay un pueblo que lo está custodiando en
la calle por eso se irrita tanto la
derecha por muy bien que tiene el pueblo
argentina para con christina es
inquebrantable
fernando y eduardo gracias por
acompañarnos y quizás lo único en lo que
coincidieron nuestros invitados es que
si va a terminar condenada por
diferentes causas como ya lo expusieron
nuestros analistas yo les doy
gracias por acompañarnos en el debate
física con más aquí en france 24
[Música]